autant les vieux face à la technologie
sont tous un peu pareil autant les
jeunes
il ya plein de types différents que
peut-être même que vous en êtes un sur
ce match à celle qui n'a plus donné moi
c'est un pitre snapshots et le cadre a
chaussé sa main devant son visage bref
on verra jamais son visage en entier
tu as caché ton visage tout le temps au
temps mais de ça l'espion isna pourtant
sans prévenir en scred tufin stop
non mais tu prévient quand tu fais un
snap c'est tout tu fais pas ça en scred
dont je fais pas de snap ça tu l'as tu
vas tu là ou pas l'horloge ça c'est le
mec qui met leur surtout c'est snap pour
montrer qu'ils se lèvent tôt ou qui se
couche très tard parce que c'est un teg
lors je suis désolé moi ça me fait
penser à ça une fois le jeu vers minuit
ils disent pourtant le chanteur on l'a
tous et snap fonds en musique il rêve
d'être chanteur me demande ce qui l'en
empêche je crois que c'est loupé sur
twitter bien évidemment sur twitter il
ya le fan de foot foot pour le potomac
you je frappe
le live tweeter c'est le mec qui va
passer toute sa soirée a commenté des
émissions télé du genre koh lanta
topchef danse avec les stars mais sur
twitter pourquoi le franchement rocher
sur l'épreuve du poteau si déjà ethiopie
d'une mini site a pas d'âme pas sur
twitter le type pas très régulier sur
twitter et pas ils bombardent pas trop
quoi c'est bon je suis enfin sur twitter
comment ça marche
en fait c'est pourri twitter ciao projet
sur l'épreuve du poteau il tient qu'à
une minute hashtag collomb sur la bad as
me bats sur twitter vaut mieux écouter
oublier bien sûr il ya les fans de monde
qu'avant car hybride
je peins que tu bandes car facebook la
jouteurs compulsif suivre en gros au
bout 4 secondes et ajoute sur facebook
rapidement
salut moi c'est etienne et moi c'est
cyprien cool
voilà et là tu appuies sur confirmer mon
pote on va plus qu'ils étaient
maintenant nikkei le stalker vous
ajoutez un ami sur facebook mais ne
poste rien ne lie que rien n a même pas
de photo de profil
pour moi c'est un espion je revois veut
toute votre vie privée
le mégalo c'est le mec qui poste ce
message
enfin j'ai fait le tri parmi mes seins
si tu lis ce message je fais partie des
personnes qui me sont proches et qui
compte cependant tu dégages hop là
instagram le mec en chien pourrait très
bien de quoi je parle a besoin d'eux a
expliqué je pense non mais tu sais que
débats n'ont pas d'influencé du fitness
1 c'est pour expliquer comment être bien
dans son corps
comment se muscler ouest pour mater des
cours parce que moi je suis dit aux gars
tu vois ça n'a rien à voir l'un ce tabou
s'il prend pas en photo son planning
bien vous avez fait votre choix
sicotte peu du jour lasagnes
végétariennes dans son abri pas c'est si
j'adore mais c'est pas beau mais quoi
qu'il ait fait aux cartes
je vais vous laisser réfléchir 1 pour
atteindre à steinbourg avec tes couleurs
de borat a exactement le hashtag heures
à photo elle est bidon par contre il a
mis tous les hashtag possibles acheteurs
unique.com ou de jetons à paris je
t'aime budget persévérance jeta
d'ambition hashtags fait pitié je tape
pas d'amis nord ouest
abattant j'en ai dit ça alors j'ai
acheté une grosse merde lâche pas que je
sus pour des like #owni hashtag chômage
c'est moi la meuf qui a tout le temps
son téléphone devant son visage qui se
prend en photo devant un miroir on
connaît son corps on verra ça gueule ça
trop changé je suis reconnaît même pas
c'est fou c'est normal je faisais de
coke
ça a très bien été yeux qu'on voit pas
mais dès que si on lui dit merci
et enfin le dernier type de personnes
sur internet celui que je préfère
particulièrement c'est celui qui a donné
à ma chaîne youtube est en fait partie
j'ai cliqué sur le nouveau bouton
youtube et juste au milieu là tu vas
voir c'est pour s'abonner comme ça tu as
pu les secours
[Musique]